[Music]
welcome to
berlin sciences for today's
panel discussion on the topic of animal experiments
we are live today in the natural
history museum berlin and surrounded by stars from the animal world here right in front of me is knut,
this is a polar bear who has attracted more than three
million visitors to
berlin  and he is a good
example of how much enthusiasm,
passion and emotions animals
can generate. that is perhaps one
reason, of course, in addition to going deeper into the
ethical questions,
why animal testing is a
controversial topic that
moves society very much and this
topic also moves and has been occupying us for
decades  in science in berlin in
particular, researchers put a lot of
energy into finding an alternative to
animal testing and today we want to
present the latest developments in
research which alternatives
are being developed to
reduce or even
replace animal testing in the future
animal experiments can be completely dispensed with
and where it is not or not yet
possible how can the general
conditions be improved in
order to find common answers eight
institutions from berlin joined forces on the initiative
of the charité and the
result was the einstein center
3 and we are today with this
panel discussion  celebrating the
creation of this center was very
promising so what is
behind these three he was are the
progress and also the limits and
above all was the goals and
perspectives of the
research we will all
discuss that together today i am very excited
and for it  we have five guests on stage
two are already with me and the
other three bets will come one after the other
and we will also
show you three films that we have also specially
prepared they give you an insight into
this research was very exciting is
but you don’t have to be and  become complex
and finally  you
dear streaming viewers and
those present here in the natural history museum have the opportunity
to ask your questions the chat
is already open from now on and you
can click on it next to stream and
already divorce your questions and
if you can't make it to the end with
us fear  the discussion
will be recorded and you will have the opportunity to watch it again
afterwards on our
youtube channel.
first of
all, i would like to welcome stefan hippenstiel and christine reinecke by my side, christine
reinigunger you are the head of the institute
for animal welfare animal behavior and you are
trying to be a customer at the free
university of berlin
you are also co-speaker of the einstein
center 3er and coordinator for the
area of teaching and training i hav
a very general quest
on for you so we are in 2021 the r
search is very very far but i
europe every year 12 million anima
s for  try used simple
question
why most of the medical
progress
is based on research on animals and almost
all nobel
prizes that have been awarded in this area are based on
animal experiments and if we look at the
progress in medicine
then we have to understand how
the mechanisms in the organism are
like  develop diseases in order to then
possibly find starting points for
therapies and that is a very
large area of basic research and t
at is also the area in which a large
number of animal exper
ments are carried out and where we are now trying to de
elop new methods using alternative methods, but at the momen
animal exper
ments in  cannot be done without in the foreseeable future then
there are completely different areas that do not play
such a large role in numbers
this is research on animal prince here
this is also the training of
veterinarians this is all
behavioral research and this is also
wild animal research  g if we
look around here now, these animals once
lived and there are researchers who
deal with wild animals in the wild
and these are areas in
which there will be
no way of doing without animal experiments in the foreseeable
future, so that means you ca
n’t either  Today you can definitely
say that it is dispensable, so
I think we have to be honest and
have to say that there are areas
where things can be completely replaced, e.g.
animal testing for cosmetics has been forbidden since 2013,
but
we are not yet in other areas  so
far that we
really have recognized, validated
alternative methods in all areas and as long as we
don't have them, some of which can
not do without animal experiments and
now we come to the
legal framework
what are the legal requirements
for being allowed to carry out animal experiments
yes, i am yes  professor of
animal welfare and
overview  ke also the whole field in which,
as you said, the
human-animal relationship has changed.
animals play a major role in
our lives and it is
amazing that it is precisely in the
area of animal experiments, which are so frowned upon, that
the biggest and strictest legal
regulations are
a guideline was issued in europe
in 2010 that applies to all of
europe and was then implemented into national
law that was in germany in 2013
and so as not to bore you with laws now
the framework is that
every researcher who plans a
scientific  to
carry out the question with an
animal, you first have to apply for this animal experiment
and there are approval authorities in every federal state
in berlin that is
the state office for health and
social affairs and there the researcher first
has to submit an application and the very
first question he has to present is
is there an alternative method and
if there is an alternative method  in order
to be able to answer this scientific question, then he is not allowed to do
any animal experiments at all, then he
will not
be approved either  makes possible and
that the housing conditions for
the test animals are gentle and
species-appropriate and that the
actinic properties of the respective species are taken into
account and that the
handling of the animals there is a
nice new word that is called
culture of care, i.e. culture of  care
that means everyone from the animal keeper to
the scientist who works with the
animals bears responsibility for these
animals and must also
deal with them accordingly and that in turn of
course requires training further education and that
is also a big issue to
train someone on the animal
apply for animal experiment apply for animal
experiment d  hat do i have to get
permission for and
accordingly the training of veterinarians
at the university is also an animal experiment that
is not known much that means that
they found it very expensive for the researchers
to get into animal experiments
that also has to list in the tänze actually
exactly and it has to  ethical
acceptability must also be set out in the application
and then there are four
test steps there are
animal welfare officers in every facility who read this application
and who also have to
write a
statement that is the first test step then
the researcher has to be there first then the
animal welfare officers within the
facility in many facilities
animal welfare committees must now also be set up have been set up they also
look at it again
and then the application goes to the authorities
and there is a section 15 commission
in berlin it is also called the ethics commission
because we are ethicists  in this
k  commission and they check again
and ultimately the decision is
made by the authorities so these are
complex tests that also
take a long time and are also very
extensive and so that you have a concrete
idea about velvet yours
we are talking about the majority of the animals
that
around 70 percent of the animals used for research are mice
and then another ten percent are rats
then there are also around ten
percent of the fish and then there are of
course other species
farm animals also
pets also primates but they are in the
range of 1 percent and  0.2 percent
and in contrast to this
, there are also very strict legal requirements
for many cases, so in
many cases animal testing
is required by law when, in other words, in
all areas where it is a question of
things being used on
humans either in  context of the approval
of drugs but also of
medicine  in products and there of substances
there are very strict regulations that
stipulate that certain things, i.e.
with medicines, must be
demonstrated that they are effective
and that they have no undesirable
side effects and then there
are toxicological studies,
so the substances are per se toxic
for use  on humans
you also have to honestly say that many
medicines that are developed for humans some time later are also often used on pets
, for example on
dogs and cats in the clinics
stephanie hilfe still you are very
welcome you are a professor of
infectiology at the  charité and
spokesman for charité 3er as well as spokesman for
the 3er center and
coordinator of the research department
why has it built a center in
berlin dedicated to animal experiments
we are less concerned with
animal experiments as such and more with
alternative methods and the environment of
animal experiments
and you have to know that berlin is an
extraordinarily large and
strong research location for
biomedicine and, as we have just
heard, animal experiments are an essential
part of biomedical
research and that automatically means
that in the state of berlin,
relatively speaking, a lot of animal experiments are carried out in the city of berlin
if you look at the
total number and
that has led to the media
giving berlin the title of the capital of animal experiments
and you just didn’t consider
that a lot of animal experiments
are carried out here because there is also a lot of
biomedical research
that worked  hand in hand with the other that
means that we in berlin naturally
also have a great need to
carry out animal experiments as optimally as possible,
also in the sense of animal welfare and
at the same time have a very great
obligation
to develop alternative methods to animal experiments both
go hand in hand and the
alternative methods place  n also a
great opportunity for science because you
can supplement animal experiments you can
open up new avenues for us that animal experiments
may not be able to take
and it was therefore obvious and
actually a logical step to
say we are going in the direction of berlin as the
capital of the  alternative methods
that doesn't mean that berlin is opposed to
animal experiments, it means
that we feel a special responsibility
to develop alternative methods here and
to take advantage of the corresponding opportunities. we are very grateful
that the house of representatives and the senate
in berlin have supported the einstein foundation
here  We have also found
great
support from the
Einstein Foundation with the appropriate financial resources and are therefore pleased
that we now have the
opportunity to work on this area together with so many institutions
and how Berlin's science is
working on research in the sense of these
three principles  you can perhaps introduce us to us
again very clearly which
is exactly what the idea is therefore
to change and improve the principle
and what does the cooperation
between these fast situation look like in concrete terms
yes maybe at the beginning what is
that even 3er has that is an
abbreviation the  on the one hand stands for called
a trend means that in an
animal experiment we try to keep the animal suffering or
that as small as possible and the
animal as large as possible and
we understand that it
starts with keeping and breeding and
that goes beyond the  entire animal experiment
up to the end of the experiment that is
called and then there is reduction in
German where it is about reducing the
number of animals that would be needed to
obtain a certain piece of information
and there are various
measures that you can take  below
that we are trying
to develop further in this center and the
third is  the so-called
replacement, i.e. the replacement of an
animal experiment, i.e. I have
something that I
would have done earlier in an animal experiment, but which I
now usually
replace with several other methods and therefore
I refrain from animal experiments, these are these
three areas
and in Berlin we have  we have now
decided
in this einstein center to concentrate on the area of
ing animal experiments that
ou have you can see t
at a very wide field if you want
o be excellent there you have to conce
trate and we have chosen this area
here we are going to  these mini
organs do research, which will also
be a topic right away, and that's what we
concentrated on, and it looks like
the best ones have found each other in a selection process from various institutions in berlin and they
are now working together on a
special organ, let's call it
that  gut and this is
characterized in more detail here the m  the model has been
expanded and there are already users
around in berlin who have found each other
who say yes we are waiting for them who are also
involved in the
process of improving the model so that in the end we have
a method that is also accepted in
science and that is
really usable  is and that helps us
to do better or different
new science in this area,
which means that this means the
development, research and
also in the Berlin area the concrete
applications of this alternative, the
goal is precisely to build up methods that are also
usable because it makes you  there is no point
in investing a lot of time and money in something
that is ultimately not
applicable and that is why we are
trying to increase the quality of these models
to make them transferrable that is a very
important approach to usability
then we will dive straight into the core of the
research and  introduce a first world of
research we are in
michael gotthard's laboratory  angen and
he and his team have developed an artificial
heart tissue
that partly enables an
alternative to animal experiments
let's see in a moment
[music]
my name is not i'm in
medicine and we work there as a
requirement you but also for the
function of the heart at the cellular
level
and  how to do everything we have to try
to develop if i end up treating
cardiovascular diseases better cardiovascular diseases are the number one
cause of death in germany even before cancer suffers every fourth
death is caused by a heart attack
or a stroke than
cardiovascular diseases are actually
very good  to treat very easy to
diagnose
but there is a large proportion of
patients who have a special form of
cardiovascular disease this is
cardiac insufficiency with a filling
disturbance so different from normal
heart disease in which the heart is not
enough point in the leadership
disorder  ngs of the heart are too stiff and as a
result less blood can be moved through the
organism and we are trying
to develop
drugs that improve this filling. this should
succeed with the help of artificial heart tissue that is grown from human
stem cells under laboratory conditions
.
artificial heart tissue or engineer
tissue is also called  ehc means this
is a
larger tissue association that replicates the
situation of the potassium minutes in the heart muscle
that is actually a very
comfortable starting point because you
map the communication between the cells and have in the system that
is stable over a long period of time this is
what artificial heart tissue looks like that
contracts  these are the two classic
sticks that connect here the
computer can see where it starts and can
then follow the contraction
how far they move towards each other and this is plotted down here in these curves which you can then
evaluate by looking at the gradient here and here
And I definitely like it here and so that
properties
elastic properties
can be described concrete knowledge can be
gained as to how
the artificial heart tissue in the
ventricular ligament of the heart chambers
would
behave  can
measure the mechanical properties
back here in a temperate
environment they feel comfortable and
you can see that from the fact that they can also be properly
controlled without us having to
stimulate them active ingredients can now be
added to the
tissue to investigate whether they cause the heart muscle cells
to do otherwise
the big difference when you have
access to home-made heart tissue is
that
you can generate any heart tissue that is the same or almost the same
, and then you can also
carry out comparative examinations
in the individual center we try to do
reduce refine replace
to replace animal experiments as much as possible
and to reduce the number of animals that works
particularly well if you
develop alternative methods, but you have to
have the right alternative
methods available and you also have to
evaluate them in comparison to the
animal model so that
the drug development can be carried out in the species
and  wisely ensures that the
results are also relevant for the
patient it is important that you do not
just treat a cell which is then more elastic or a heart muscle
tissue that is better
launched it is also important that
the drug then has an effect in the organism and it is
important that  of course you only pursue all approaches
with the best
drug that has the highest chance
that it will also help a patient
go into the mouse model because these are very expensive
and very lengthy investigations
welcome michael gott
has seen you you are the
research group leader at the
max  -delbrück center for  molecular
medicine member of the steering
committee in the 3er boarding center and you are leading
a research project there
we have just seen now there is
this artificial heart tissue it means
that
animal experiments are no longer needed for research on cardiovascular diseases
that depends on what the
research interest is  so if you
want to know how a protein is structured
and how its current
can be simulated by springs you no longer need to
count if you want to know
how heart muscle cells contract then
you can do it in individual parts
but if you want to know how
cells communicate with each other and work together in the tissue network
and working together with an
extracellular
matrix then you have to build a
more complex system and that would be
an artificial heart tissue but a
situation such as embryonic development
how heart muscle cells are made from a cluster of
cells which then form into
the tube which then
rotates and forms a real heart that
's too complicated to show that outside of the
organism and it's exactly the
same for medication if you have
a complex disease in which, for
example, high blood pressure and
diabetes or diabetes together
reduce the heart function, you ca
n't just do that in the tissue  replicating that
means that works if I
understand correctly if you
are looking for a certain thing and then
you can take organs for this
and everything else that concerns the connections
then it doesn’t work
anymore you can do many things that
affect the heart muscle  affect yourself in
this artificial heart recreate
tissue you can also process even more complex
situations by
inserting additional cells such as vascular cells
or the immune system, but the things that come from
outside such as
stress or hormonal influences
can be partly recreated with
molecules that you  the one just in  s medium
, however, there are more complex things like sport
it's not that easy
you can't do that yet on the coast heart
tissue no
that will you can challenge them so
you can let them work against a stronger
resistance or you
can stimulate them with adrenaline so
that they close  work similarly as in the
weakened organism but that is
not the right life and why is
it like that you think they
even said that heart diseases are
jesus is extremely widespread
it was researched for a long time and medicines were
also developed why is it
so complex that  you
still need this research
the complexity is related to the
fact that there
are a lot of cells that
work together now there are these individual
technologies with the man
what you can see how many different
cells there are in the tissues
and that is a complex situation when
cells  different at different points in
the wall of the heart
muscle  physical mechanical
properties have to be represented and
are exposed to different influences
and you can't reproduce that in such a
tiny artificial heart tissue
and for this it is important to
see which questions you can address in such a
reduced system and
you can see whether you understand the complexity
better  can and whether one can also
reproduce complexity better by
aryanizing or irritating heart muscle tissue, for
example, that
one can give impulses that
would also come in the organism but in
a less complex
context okay we are first of all we have
started with not replacing everything that is
but it can
also replace that a lot in which
cases can it specifically
replace animal testing, for example when you test drugs
or active ingredients yes,
drug development is a
long-term process and that several
stages are best if you understand the
disease
it works  in different  noble systems,
for example a mutation of one
go there you can see what the protein
does and you can possibly
understand that in the cell and then you can
see whether you can change it and
there may also be in a
single cell or in the tissue and
if you have a small molecule that
influences the heart function, then it
makes sense to test it first in a simple
system and then
to go more and more complex and at some point it will be
ruled out because, for example,
in the 3d heart tissue it does not reach the
cells enough, so maybe a
single culture will  but not in the 3d
tissue and you can then
take that out of the development and
take the next one and if the
next drug creates this threshold
then the question would be whether
it is also available in the animal model, for example
, if you either
inject it or through the  there is food and
then some fall out again
and if some fall out again
s  ind you can go into the next more complex
animal system i.e. and from the mouse
maybe into a rat and then you have to keep looking
successively it’s
holding medication and you have to
look it has side effects and by looking
you can of course
judge much better if you’re in complex
organism is as if you are in an
artificial heart tissue so a
job never an arrhythmia
i see that sometimes in individual cells but
then i wouldn't be able to say whether, for
example, medication would lead to the
patient going blind or
getting depressed it doesn't work at all
and  that means again to present it specifically
if you are working on a new
product or recyclable material
if there weren't this alternative where
you can do it right away and animal experiments
and because there are these artificial heart
walkways there is then an
intermediate stage of the experiment, so to
speak  before it can go at all right here
try have now
another filter
where we were able to
sort out medicines that don't have to go in style
and that's a great help and it's
known but can even be improved
so at the moment we have
a very simple artificial
heart tissue you could maybe improve it so
that you can pick up more side effects
and  this reduces even more
animal experiments
one also understands that the complexity of
the connections between the
various organs is so high that
the entire
body needs to function the body
actually needs it is raw are
here now that we have human
tissue or are artificial had
such advantages on the  tests that
it is not about animals
but yes what is human exactly there
are drugs that are the small
molecules overplayed they have an effect
that is relatively easy to
imagine but there are also
drugs that attack the genetic information
and the genetic information the  is
below  there is a difference between mice and
humans and if we develop a small
molecule that downregulates no walking
then it might work
out really great but the same
would not work
for patients because we already know that the sequence is
different and then we basically
have to  people make medicines
and that people ca
n't make medicines in the testing and
known then very laboriously identify a
humanized one that then
practically has the human gene but
that's a lot of work and it's much
nicer if you can make the artificial
heart move which is nice
has the human sequence of its own accord and
treats the artificial tissue and then
you don’t always have to give a
sick heart to treat
it, you can also assess the effectiveness
if you simply have normal
human heart tissue they say
it’s a filling disorder and  it's too
stiff and goethes likes to treat then
ka  nn of course i
try to make a diseased heart muscle tissue a
stiff one or i can take normal one
the normal one
becomes less stiff and that works too
and since when have you been working with
this artificial heart tissue for about
three years and we don’t have it on
customers that  is now even a
commercial system and that's really
great because it makes it much easier to
spread it and in the
recruiting center we try to be a
multiplier it's of course a lot of work
that not everyone can put up with seeing something like a film
but it is totally easy
to give other groups access and
to support them so that they
can also do some of their experiments in this system and we see
it as our task to advise
our colleagues which questions
can be addressed in artificial heart tissue and for
which ones  even just the cells
would need ode  r for which
question you would have to go to the animal model
and if you have to go to the hotel
for that you also have
animal experiments in the laboratory too many
for the cases exactly and you work
less with it now or you can do it but
a few less more and more  but
the
four models that are indispensable
and we always need them, but we
can do better and more relevant
animal experiments, so before we were
able to do more targeted and precise very well,
on the other hand, thank you very much, we go
on to the laboratory again at the core of the
research, each of us knows this 3d
print times are from the
industry you make objects with plastic or some
other material
in jens kurreck's laboratory they also work
with 3d printers
but instead of plastic they
work with human tissue and
mini organs are created from it that's very
fascinating  we already look to
professor jens kurreck and his
team at the institute for
b  iotechnology of tu berlin a 3d
model
can be implemented with a 3d
printer that prints from human cells or
in mini format
. we focus primarily on two
organs, the liver and the lungs,
and these use various
questions from the biomedical
field  for example, for
infection research in the lungs
, the flu virus, the influenza virus, is of course an option
and in
cooperations we now also work a lot with the
corona virus for the liver, we would
then prefer to have specific ones that
we examine what is special about our
models is that they are three-dimensional
and that they consist of human
cells, that means we have a
human system that produces very relevant
results for biomedical
research and is therefore also interesting for
the pharmaceutical industry
. the aim is to replace animal experiments
with 3d models from human tissue
cultures in
biomedicine  Inian research it is so
that we have two different paths we
have cell cultures on
the one hand and animal experiments on the other hand
animal experiments simply lead to so much suffering
and of course we always want to
try to
reduce them whenever possible the problem with 2g is to do with
us  have shown that the flat
mono bins are connected to each other and we just don't have any
three-dimensional interactions between
the cells
side effects we have
ineffectiveness and that of course means that
we need improved options
to be able to achieve really human-specific results, that's why the development of alternative methods is being promoted on
behalf of the einstein 3r center
first of all bioethics who mix
our
biopolymers in this case with eg
we have eigenart and your team there
are 1 natural polymers are derived from
plants or animals there are
also synthetic polymers which we often use
as additional substances, for example
to
improve certain printing properties  or one to count the
freshly used bio ink is then
used in different
printing processes this is for example a glp printer this
is digital light processing
this actually just means that our bio inc is
not hardened over most of the
organ models are made with a
pneumatic printer  with the help of
compressed air the whole
thing works like this in this printer a few
cents there is a compressor and
this compressor generated compressed air and
this compressed air the things these small
hoses it is guided through
and we see it on these
shooing the printer tables and into the
croatian  b  If the bio is found,
however, the consequences have been scheduled and
the whole thing works so that this
compressed air causes this
bio inc to explode from the cartridge, in this
case the bread world with the 24
corrugated plates
small square model that can be used as a
fabric or structural
model when we have finished printing the model
there are times in there life and we
cultivate them for a certain period of time
and that's important for us to
know how well the cells are
experimentally tuned brand they put
die for this we then have
different methods and use, for
example, this fund here as well. ie
the marca
marked
by our constructors
with various
firus tanks  forever colored here now series
we see like here in
red and
bl  ow are the cell nuclei so
we can say okay the constructs or the
cells in the constructs express
these markers and they're fine and
they survived the printing
process another goal and editing is it
that would represent something like a blood vessel
structure and here  we
have a so-called polarized
organ model you can already
see the inlets and outlets sort of
broken down into individual slices which
the printer can later build up piece by piece
and if we
go through the model now we can see
the bottom here and then it will be  and
built up layer by layer exactly
and here we now see the structure
that is released this
mobilization is important because we let
the medium flow through here
and the cells are naturally supplied
with it and that gives us
the biologically correct situation that
we  blood vessels everywhere in the body
have the organ model with the
printed s  structure has to be
tested first and we first want
to use a colored solution to see whether the
vessels have really stayed open and
can flow through and
then in the actual experiment you could,
for example, flush cytostatics to choose from
, a tumor disease or
antivirals against a virus
infection, yes  of course we now want to use our models
in many
research projects,
for example we have a
cooperation project with albert
bräunig from the federal institute for risk assessment
and here we want to investigate the toxicity of
substances on the liver and
the interesting thing is
then to compare the results with results from animal studies in
order to  see if you
find similarities or differences here,
then we have cooperation
projects with partners from the charité and the courage of the
free university berlin for
virus research and in all
cases we want to offer our models in the
sense of the 3 r geda
nken to replace animal experiments
in school welcome
you are professor of applied
biochemistry at the tu berlin also co-
spokesman of the einstein center 3er and
coordinator of the communication area
the first question is what is the difference
between your model and the organs
model that we have seen fire
first of all we deal with
different organs
we saw the beating
heart that is of course impressive
dealing with the lungs and the liver
but there are also slightly different
approaches which are not no
contradiction but
complement each other michael gott  has
poured his heart muscle cells into
certain shapes which yes we
saw while we were printing
that means we can first
arrange different cells in different spatial areas very precisely in the
approaches where you don’t use a printer
, you also build more on your own
organs  ational power tells you that
you form the fabric yourself, then
that you naturally have it while
we give it to you and the whole thing
can also be brought together
, for example by first printing a fabric
roughly and then through this
self-organizational power the
fine structure then
develops naturally  that means after that
the recreated nature does the actual
citizen work itself it does its own work
exactly that is the idea behind it
exactly that is fascinating and where
do these human cells come from we have different sources so
in biomedical
research we first work a lot with
cell cultures
these are
cecilia  these are cells that are often
cancer cells from people who are then
immortal, for example, the
most famous cell line is the so-called
hel hela cell line, which originates
from henrietta lacks in the 1950s
Unfortunately, the patient died relatively shortly afterwards
, but to this
day virtually every
biomedical laboratory still works with these cells. Being
immortal. Yes, exactly. There is also
a very nice book, The
Immortality by Henrietta Lacks, which is
well worth reading. It is about these
cells
are tumor cells is characterized
by the fact that they grow very quickly
yes and that's why we can keep cultivating them in
the laboratory
there are also so-called primary counts
these are cells that
still occur during operations, for example, or
organ donations if an organ could not be
transplanted  then you can
use that for research these
cells give us physiologically even more
relevant data but cannot
be cultivated for a very long time and can
not be preserved on a large scale and
so the spearhead of research are
now counting those obtained from the so-called
induced pluripotent stem cells
these ips
are made from adult cells,
for example from a skin cell, you can reprogram the
cells back into
a basic state so that they allow
other cells to
differentiate again, so that’s my
pluripotency and then i can make liver cells out of these
pluripotent stem
cells, for example, which i  then inserts
for the organ models so they do
n't apply to you and the basic material for
the replica is very valuable
because we need a lot of cells
the cell cultures from the cell
lines we can make them on a large scale but
they also have the least
physiological relevance  the cells from
these pluripotent stem cells
are difficult to obtain in huge quantities,
but they are becoming much more physiologically
relevant, so you always have to make
compromises,
for example, first optimizing with a
cell line and then ultimately excluding
primary cells or these differentiated
cells  the ips takes and what are where
do you
still see the
current limit and the
development potential of your models
so when we look at our models
it reminds me a bit of
the optimists and pessimists, whether a
glass is half full or half empty
i think we have  we have already done a
lot so not we our group
but the researcher community with
this 3d model and there is still a
lot to do e.g. michael gott has
already mentioned that we
need the different cell types an
organ consists of a lot of
cell types the  have liver we
not only have the liver cells hepatocytes
but we have star cells copper
cells synodal cells android being
everything possible and now we have to
manage to integrate more and more cell types into our
models and these have
to work together like in the
actual organ  be brought into
communication within
the organ and
a very special h  The challenge is
the immune system. We are working on this with
our young model, for example
in corona research.
Of course, we also need to
somehow depict the immune reaction and that is something
that many groups are working on intensively,
but where you cannot say for sure
that we have reproduced it exactly  how it is
tomorrow it is there where is still
most like that in the ministry in male
bodies there is always
this immunity yes so the monologues
were now of course also saying yes we
have already done a lot of
research the knowledge is of course also very large
but  reproducing this immune reaction in a
3d model is still
extremely challenging and
that we have already heard that the models
have to be the organs i mean they have
to interact with each other
we have so-called micro-
physiological systems on which several
organs interact  to be
brought into communication sometimes there is
a  also the buzzword young nun chip
if we are yes and we are focusing
on individual organs at the moment
and there too we can come together again in the future
that for these
chips where the organs are brought into
communication the
more complex 3d models that we are
developing now  for example in the
einstein center that they are integrated there and
then brought into communication,
for example then testing how a
drug is metabolised in the liver in the
first place is activated
is possibly toxic and then
has an effect on the heart muscle that
something like this is brought into communication
you also have  seen that I can now
even break down these blood vessels
and can one also imagine a larger
model in the future that rather
the human being could be rebuilt as entire 3d models
terrible
so it is unimaginable for us at the moment
but if I look
down
right now if I look  imagine in ancient
gri  echenland a naturalist that
will also could not imagine
could not imagine that you could fly to the
moon or that you with mr after
vaccines the corona virus with you yes
so we have to think about it that
can be in the future maybe it
can actually be  and so i
would set a very strict ethical
limit there, that of course you
shouldn’t reprint people, so
what we want are research models
that deliver medical
results relevant to humans or tissue that
can be transported, that there is
also something that is a realistic
scenario for  but the foreseeable future
is now a whole human being that is
more of a horror idea
we could of course have an hour-long ethical discussion now you
said yourself that 3
the human being would be printed as a 3d model so
what status would this human being
have if you  now, for example,
could reprint with now  if i want to
stand here again i will be my
model once i have the same
ethical rights and obligations that i have
as a natural human being so
let's hope that humanity retains the consensus
never to do something like that
we hope that but for now you can
maybe  Introducing a few
functioning organs or replicated
organs that can communicate and that
would be a first step,
hopefully useful, that
we can use it to develop new cancer drugs new
virus drugs in
a very realistic setting with
human cells and not with
animal cells human system
because  this model that you built
for lungs that can also be made from other
organs that is basically there are
bio-printing processes for all possible
organs, i.e. every organ we
focused on at some point said
we are now mainly making lungs and
liver with, for example, also a tumor model  in
a in a n  close environment
so there you are very open that you can
transfer and to other organ systems
and if you say that you then compare the
results because you also achieve
medium animal models what kind of
knowledge could you draw from it
by a stilt man we just  only just
started but we work together with the
federal institute for
risk assessment, so one
of our project managers is from this
institute there, for example, you have in-
vivo data on the toxicity of
pesticides and now you can
see how it behaves when we
put these pesticides in  it
is
similar to using our printed liver, although you then even
have to take the step
and we thought about that too, that you then
replicate an animal organ because if we
want to check the reactions we have to first print the animal organ
and then  can we print the human
organs and then draw conclusions
then we'll see if there's a
loss because we
have to draw conclusions about how this pesticide
can affect people.
that also comes with so much
commitment  so for those who also like
to do the experiments, he
actually has that is a very important
aspect, it's always about
validation in the sense that the
results we have are credible,
that's really a result that you can
repeat, that you can do something too
something else can be transferred and
the problem with animal experiments that are carried out
for human medicine is often that
it is said that the results from
animals are not so easily transferrable to
humans and
from this point of view one must of course
if one generates an alternative model from
human cells
and  that wants to validate and
that makes use of animal studies is the
logical in between  step that you first create
the animal model and
exactly as it was correctly
described and in fact it would of course
also be the numerically
smaller area for the areas where
research for animals is also interesting
to then have models for animals yes
interesting maybe  also a small
thought about it in the end it is about the
fact that we
want to develop new methods for humans and for the
alternative methods, as
for the animal experiments, of course it also applies that in the
end we always have to prove to what extent the
model actually reflects the reality in
humans that means
for  both parts we need better
quality and repeatability and
we always have to think about how we can
test on real human tissue
or on patients that we
actually measure what we claim to measure
and that it is really transferrable
and that applies to the world of
animal testing as well  as for the world
of old  native methods
thanks
here comes our many thanks
our third film one of the pioneers
who deals with the topic of
alternatives i think very much professor andreas
hocke he and his team also
develop
3d lung models from infectiology at the charité from human
stem cells are cultivated
organs also organs  called and this model
has also
proven to be a very solid alternative
in the corona period, give you an insight into his laboratories
[music]
15 years ago, it decided to use graves as an
alternative to animal experiments and used them to
simulate severe infections
and inflammations and I would be
happy to show you that in the  laboratory demonstration with my
team
pneumonia is the most common
infectious
disease worldwide and, despite the use of effective
antibiotics, still leads
to the death of around one in ten
patients  lung of 3d lung models in
mini format patient
donations placed so that the tissue is transported
in our laboratory under life culture conditions
prepared and further used for
infection research i
work with the tissue directly that means
that all cell types are curtained in a
very filigree  tissue structure the
advantage the test results on human
tissue provide directly meaningful
results in relation to the disease in
humans, but first the quality must be
checked,
i.e. whether the talk about the medium is correct that
indicates a gas exchange also whether there is a
stage, i.e. liquid instead
oxygen that will mean that the
tissue floats below and one also
pays attention to andrack tables mixes
places so-called coal flow what is in the
air from smoking or and from
inhaling how is the tissue healthy
enough it is crushed and
the tissue is prepared for targeted infections
example  Infected with influenza or corona
viruses but also with
bacterial pathogens, all of which
trigger severe pneumonia,
have succeeded in taking a different approach.
Modern doctor analysis is being pursued and this has the
following reason:
the disadvantage of the fresh flower
tissue is something we cannot
cultivate for a long time
and that is why we tend  to also use this
lung and then
ultimately
to isolate the adult stem cells here and
to generate organoids, i.e. an organ-like
microstructure of the lung that we can then
cultivate over a longer period of time
and the advantage is that we
can also look at it like
I imagined  you can also
see very clearly we are complaining they are actually
so we have here in yellow of 100
micrometers on a scale and that is now
200 micrometers the disadvantage organo lidl
do not yet provide the complete
composition of a human
pulmonary alveoli star there are missing, for example, the immune cells and
we can isolate them and then later in the
organs one is what i'm
working on with my students there
just to get a competent model
for that a saline solution is injected and then
you can see very nicely how
it puffs up exactly what yes  the
lungs also normally do when you breathe in air
to really
get the cells out now i massage
the cells out of the lungs then what is
swimming here in the liquid that
becomes so cloudy are then the cells i
am interested in under the microscope
it becomes visible whether the previous organs
have survived the cultivation, the
cells communicate properly
with each other and we can now
reflect our experiments through the targeted infections
in which cell types of the
lung viruses can multiply and what
damage they cause can be made visible
with a special
professor
hoppe has the light microscope ready for this  s infected young
models under für renz light proteins in
the cells are made
visible with different colored markers
and show how different
the reactions to bacterial toxins
or viruses are here we see a
cross section through a human
alveoli the black space is
the air space that is the delicate
tissue structure  through which the gas exchange
of oxygen and carbon dioxide
takes place and
if viruses or bacteria get into this area in this area
then
damage can occur, so this can be shown
in this example here you can see
a completely different picture you can see
individual cells that in  fall into the air space
and die and thus
the gas exchange function is also destroyed
we also simulate the same thing on
these organoids here is a small
illustration with a film here you
can see these organs the lakes in their
structure completely different they
organize themselves  it is also similar to
lung tissue in three dimensions and
reflects the cells of the lung
tissue and what you see here in the
film is that green
dots suddenly appear and this green coloring shows
us how a bacterial poison a
bacterial toxin is actually able to
infect these cells  destroy
and we can use these models well
to test therapeutic substances as part of
the curve 19 pandemic it
has been shown that we have to react very quickly in
order to investigate infectious
agents at the beginning of a pandemic like this there
are no animal models available and the
models in the infection context also
reflect  very rarely the situation of
people again for the reason,
both human lung tissue
and the organs generated from it are
excellently suited to very quickly
achieve robust results in connection
, for example, with such an
infection process as that
actually leads to immune reactions in the lungs
severe inflammation and also
partly to the
destruction of the lung tissue
stephanie evan stille you have
seen these 3d lung models developed with andreas hocke
one of the
difficult task the great
challenge in the voices of this
model is due to the durability of
the young model pension explain
how you do it
thank you very much we have a great
team that makes all this work
possible in the first place and this knowledge and
we have found as a team that
this primary lung tissue that we get from the
patient that can be examined for about
a week with good
quality can have
longer-term effects  you
didn't examine it so an
alternative had to be found secondly it's so
that this tissue is also difficult
to freeze away you can't produce it
in stock,
so to speak so we went this
route of establishing these lung organoids in the
laboratory for different areas d  he lungs
for the airways and for the lungs where
you actually breathe the lower area
and you can really
examine them for months and that of course gives
us new
opportunities to examine longer-term effects
, but you always have to
know that every model has its strengths
and weaknesses  and as was just said in the film
, immune cells are still missing there
and now you have to see
how do you get them in there and how
do you get them with good
quality reproducible over and over again
and those are the
challenges we are facing at the moment but me
I assume that the long-term shelf life is
so that also allows for the
long-term side effects or after-effects of
a substance yes in
principle it is possible of course
if you make a change to
see what happens in the long term
but I would like to point out that
drug side effects
also often result from
processes  the i  n different
organs play a role as it has
already happened several times today and of
course i can't simulate that if i
only have my piece of lung in an
examination and that also makes the
challenge with the
alternative methods clear again
we just have to bring things together
and  this field is only at the beginning and
that is why there is also the
einstein center because we have a great need for
development here yes yes we
can examine long-term things there
but by no means everything and
medicines will only be used to a
very limited extent as we see it
at the beginning we see this insane
development
potential that offer as an alternative but we also saw
it at the end of the film
that also
played a very important role during the corona pandemic time if you explain to
us in more detail how
it was used and whether it was used
models made it possible to have a
very very s  A vaccination
came quickly, ok, so I'll share my answer, thanks
, in two of the same kind. The first is what
could we do with it, what did we do
with it, we looked,
does the virus grow in there in relation
to other viruses and what destroys it,
what happens  there on site and the
crazy thing we measured there
was this classic pathogen of the flu
influenza viruses that grew really great
have multiplied the corona virus
itself that is causing us grief here at the moment
but is only growing very badly
in the lungs that makes you wonder
one asks oneself, yes,
what does that actually mean and we
were then able to determine on the basis of more detailed
examinations that
there is no strong
growth in the lungs themselves, but
that certain immune mechanisms
are activated there and these immune mechanisms
they now seem to be essential to the
fact that people can get
sick or at least some of them can
yes that means in human
lung tissue you could make an
important contribution to understanding the
disease but for the strength
of the model namely the first phase i.e.
the first day what happens there in the
lung now to your question about the
vaccination a very simple answer
nothing because this model is
not made for that it is not its
orientation and every model has strengths
and weaknesses and
this model is not suitable for examinations
and vaccination in particular is an interaction
of many things from the spleen to the
various lymph nodes and and goes
on  weeks and that's a really
big challenge for the
alternatives here to animal testing, to
actually find a way to
recreate something like the moon landing of the alternatives, so to speak,
and you have to honestly
admit that it's a distant goal, yes, and
that's true  it's hard to work at
so it becomes very active too  ive and
diligently worked the beginners
center 3 and so we are only doing a
lot of energies from different areas
together to
enable us to get as far and as quickly as
possible animal experiments are not only
in the medical area for
basic research or  the approval
of 1 1 billion years just said
in the einstein center three he also takes part in
another institution
hello welcome mrs
tanja Schwerdtle and that is the federal institute
for risk
assessment you are the wyss president of the bfn also a
university teacher and member of the
steering committee in the einstein center
3rd welcome why is it
important that your institution is also on
board the einstein center
to answer this question comprehensively
i have to go back a bit and
would also like to
point out the small clip
yes maybe it would be best if we
us to  st very good then let's get
started right away very good idea
we have a short presentation of the
institute as a microphone a bit closer
to it exactly thank you to the exactly German
center for the protection of
laboratory animals let's take a look right away [music] the Oberallgäu work is  at hausen
conditions to make the
next generation
access to be able to test whether
you want to touch me to animal testing
bolt
[music]
we
at
the federal institute for risk assessment take on the role and the task of the
german  center for the protection of
laboratory animals that the activities that are being copied here are an important part of the animal welfare initiative of the
Federal Ministry of Food and
Agriculture what exactly are we doing there
we coordinate
all the activities nationwide that pursue two important
common goals our first
goal is  similar to boarding
along with boarding 3 r the  to reduce the number
of animal experiments to the absolute
minimum
, but we still have a second goal, that
's what we actually share with 3
r, we also want to make animal
experiments as good as
possible for the animals, that's what we've
already heard we have to offer  in the
refrain that means that the well-being of the
animal experiments is extremely important to us in the
context of our tasks it is also
so that the focus of our
activities at the federal institute is the protection of
the protection of human health
it now looks like
a conflict situation and me
I would also like to briefly explain that means we
research for this, we communicate for this
and we do risk assessments
I heard that at the beginning
and if you assess risks then
you do it scientifically because
we are independent
that means we use everything that is in
the literature  other researchers and
science produce knowledge here  we do
exactly that sometimes for the
evaluation of certain substances also because
i have some momentum
pesticides today chemicals
but also medical products and other
things naturally occurring substances in
food that can be harmful
such as mold toxins we need
a toxicological evaluation and here
there are often and  protecting the safety of the
consumer is not yet a
comprehensive alternative that means
we at the federal institute for
risk assessment know exactly
where the gaps are for the toxicological assessment
similar to the other
institutions, we are also researching here
to develop alternatives together, as
we have heard with our colleagues and
colleagues in berlin, but also
throughout germany and internationally
what we also
do is in the area of validation harmo
ization what we have already heard
we have heard that there is often a need
o have comparable alternative test systems i  n th
regulatory if we
want to ensure that a substance is approved
that it is safe for humans
for consumption we also have to
ensure that if it is tested by
different institutions or
people using an
alternative method that gives the same
result we have to
harmonize validate it
our scientists are also involved in
many international committees and
test guidelines, for example, to
ensure and further
develop them. in addition, we have many other
activities that we pursue in the area
of communication in the area of infor
from scientists. we have alread
heard today that there are many altern
tive models, very important a
ternatives  models but we
also noticed that it is
sometimes very difficult to find the right alternative method even in the great
jumble of science and the many
databases
i would like to come back
to this d  he role you have in this,
you bear a very great responsibility
that the products that reach the population
are so safe
and how do you actually work on
using these alternative methods, which we
have already
presented, and perhaps
also on appropriate regulations  develop
that they can also be used
yes we work
in which later for the regulatory
use the rule
astoria is examination for you your case failed
we are working on it that we work according to
guidelines that means applicable
guideline how to do that of chemical
experiments  know how to know that from
recipes that must be
standardized that must
be correct in terms of content be
comprehensible we are working on this,
for example, and not alone that
is not our primary task but
internationally in a team that the
international guidelines that are being
developed are scientifically
correct and implemented  zbar and also
allow valid statements possibilities you think the key
word validation
is a very important aspect because the
research on alternatives is a
great thing but it really has
to come to the point that it is also checked as a
process
and a law will also win  right area we
have to be sure what that which is
tested afterwards also brings
us the important quantitative result
, namely if it is
tested by different areas
in the classic analysis in the
analysis of active substances regardless of the
system if we only examine one substance and
in what concentration  it
happens the validation is
normal everyone does that but with the alternative
methods we are still at the beginning and
we are actively working on
improving this process and beyond
the
[music]
medical research that we have already
seen this artificial
heart tissue the  3d model the organo iden
se  Do you also see
further perspectives or possibilities in
the working method that can reduce animal experiments
so it would be better to combine all the
knowledge we have
collected so far and to even better avoid
animal experiments the $100
question
the scientist has
ideas here  and sees perspectives otherwise
we wouldn't be scientists we
've already heard today that there are approaches
in which computer-based methods are compared with
what is done in the laboratory using
high-tech technology, with a
3d model mr kurth presented it
we try to compare what we have in animal experiments
with what we have in
the models we can use
ki today for this we can stretch that further
with the open data policy
we will have access to a lot more data, including
from the human sector if we
could process it and combine it
intelligently with the 3d models then we
could  we make the jumps we
couldn't do it in the last decades
that was
my very personal hopes my very personal wish
i see it similarly i just want to
point out
the fruits hang very high so
i think we have to take a look we
come from the academic world here there
is an industrial one  world where you say
okay a drug is being developed there
are regulations
pharmacological developments that's
a world we come from the
academic world smaller laboratories and
don't want to offend anyone but small
groups we are all not 100
people strong who work on special
models and  so on and there
is a lot of variety, that's an
advantage, but i'll say the
validation is rather low and that's
something we want to work on, for
einstein we want to try
to improve the quality of these academic laboratories at the university
and here too  to create more comparability
I think but ma  I have
to say again and again because of
course the question keeps coming up will you
reduce the number of animals you have to
keep in mind that this is a
very, very difficult process and
if you think about
it, there is a big plan for that in the USA
runs until 2027 to map the human brain
a little better
and then you spend 6.6 billion dollars
just to
see what it actually looks like now,
let alone that someone is now
starting to recreate it now the
brain likes a very complex one  be an example
and the lungs and also one may
forgive me the heart citizen be a bit
easier but nevertheless
the challenge is great there and
often we don't even know which
cells are in there and that's why
i think we have to be clear again and
again  we are embarking on a
really difficult, rocky, long
path that requires a lot of investment and commitment
and that  we have to
make it clear to ourselves again and again that
we do
n't awaken any scientifically untenable
hopes of our day yes we also
want to stay in reality just
not like women in science fiction
or in the utopia world but that's
very well the most normal
contextualization  and to
bring it down to earth that means today and in the
next few years you will still
need to try what this 3-
centre center is also committed to is
that a person called out and how
they concretely said that means we will
need the animals we can  but
improve your living conditions in the general conditions and that is
also one of the commitments can you
also tell us specifically what that
looks like yes i think at
least point out that he beautiful also at 1
we already knew each other to some extent before
from joint projects because we
everyone has a common goal and called
one there is a joint project
between e  u and the federal institute
for risk assessment and i would
leave that to the scientist to present this
yes think we have the appointment to
a professorship together professor lewejohann we
saw him in the clip and
experience johann is a behavioral biologist is
associated with me at the institute at the
fau and
works  but at the bfr and we work
together in the excellence
cluster xii
and have the focus enemy from the
perspective of the animal and mr lewe
yuan
has now
developed a large enclosure to reflect the near-natural
housing conditions of the animals
and we are
also trying the methods and  to
automatically
analyze the
behavior with colleagues from the tu and to understand the animals' behavior better
that is the aspect that is good for the
excellence cluster and
at the same time if this
technology succeeds in establishing it,
validating it then sharing it with everyone like that
that we the n  you can use, for
example, to monitor animals in animal experiments in their
cage 24 hours a day, seven days a week
and then you click on
your cell phone a message the mouse in the
cage 7 row three is not doing well
look at it like this so that's
it too  a vision for the future that
will also take a while until
that happens, but we are working on
things like that and the other point
is, and for me that is also
applied feynman and that's why i
have the role in the einstein center for
teaching that we just do the training
design and improve very well and
also harmonize across all the institutes
that are represented in the einstein
center and there are new specifications
from the eu and we are now
trying to establish a modular system across berlin
in which the training
for the field of animal experiments and
then  and that's brand new at
the einstein center, the
methods that are established by the experts
and de  n individual groups are not only used for
their own group, but
are shared with the doctoral students and
scientists in a stone
center by being
passed on, we see this is
that the fields in
which research is carried out are very broad and the ambitions are very
high  that's really great we'd like to
open up the audience after our discussion, but before that i'd
like to invite our two other guests
back on stage for
maybe three sentences for each as a
final word as he might have the
most important message or where the
challenge  there are still maybe
three sentences each and then we can
gladly take your question
sir correct
that was not prepared
correspond to the challenge is
to make better and better models and above
all to go to the colleagues who
currently still regard the animal experiments as
indispensable and those of them  to
convince here you have tried an alternative
those from we have a
little bit of these two communities who
absolutely want to make alternative methods
and who say that there is no
other way and to involve the industry here, for example,
to use these models those were
more than 3 again very good yeah me  go in a
similar direction has from the other
side i think it's really important
to develop alternative methods,
but it's also really difficult to
judge whether you have a real
alternative and should therefore be discussed in the
working group or in
the company or in politics  there is always
someone at the table who is doing experiments himself,
preferably who is
doing animal experiments and developing alternatives
i think the one of the most important
challenges is
to communicate transparently here we have to communicate honestly
where do we
still need animal experiments to protect consumers
or to develop medical products
we have to trust ourselves
and  also be able and there has to
be acceptance because we
ultimately don’t decide what the consumer
or the patient needs,
yes, of course, I stand for that, cried a
man, and more for the laboratory animals, and
I wish that as long as we
need laboratory animals, we will work to
ensure that  the attitude is as good as
possible, the training is as good as
possible and we also continue to develop and improve
the we find measures in this area
now i'm the last one
it's important to me that three research in
an ethically great context
can create innovations for better
care of
patients and i would just like to call on all young people all young
scientists hey it's just fun it
's just good and it brings great
science to the ground and that's why
just join in
think we have very positive words here that's enough
of the chat now  a few
spectators  I'll get the question I
'll read it out and see who of you
is sure to have the most own leading
answer.
You can combine the different
organ models and
test the effect of
medication on the heart, lungs, liver and so on in a single experiment.
Yes, these are microphysiological
systems that I have already dealt with very briefly
the viewers of the
viewers found a very central
question and here too we are working
on it, so we can already
create connections, but it must
certainly be optimized further so that
we really manage to make these complex
organs  interacting with each other a
problem is, for example, this is a
very banal scientific or
research problem that one
organ feels more comfortable in the medium
the other in another
medium and now you have to find something
where both feel comfortable in it, i.e.
live in the long term and then
combine it like this  be like it in de  r
physiology is also a very
central point that was addressed here
then I come to the next question do
you know about all organs
generate organoids and are some also
more suitable for it
everything is possible you have to see what
helps if I now have an organ ohrid for
a salivary gland is perhaps
not needed now,
the most urgent problem insofar as
we
have already imaged
most of the important organs in different quality and
it will be very difficult to
image the complete brain, but we have replicated small parts
that help us to reduce animal experiments
are always available here
in the  hall questions from viewers
directly into a microphone that we are happy to pass around
first not then we want to
ask the next question from viewers how
big can organs get and are there
limits yes
they can get amazingly big
is several millimeters
so you can  then the naked eye see
the brain of all things  organo ide
become so big for whatever reason
at some point there is
usually a nutritional problem because in
a normal organ you
have blood vessels and these blood vessels are used,
among other things, to
transport food and remove
waste and
most places have that  organs not so far
that means the oxygen transport
happens passively through diffusion
the substances have to get in there you can
easily imagine inwards it is
becoming less and less on the one hand and
on the other hand so gases and
things like that can get worse in the
middle in becomes acidic  and cloudy and one
is lonely and then it can
lead to these organs dying off
from the inside from a certain size
and that is a kind of
limitation and maybe
these microfluidic systems are
a way out there one has
found that when they are surrounded
by water  and if in such a circular
toric circles  nd system are then they
can grow much better bigger
and they change again in the
process, so they can become relatively
large and of course I
have to be enthusiastic about bioprinting again
that we can print the vessel
structures there that
could of course be  also help to make it
bigger so that it doesn't all
die off
the next question how long does it take to
view this artificial
heart tissue and how can it also be
printed
that's important we have about a million
cells per r ht we have to let them
grow first  it takes a few
weeks but you can also
lie down in frieser a little bit and then fetch it
when you need it and then they have to be
sown, they then have to form a
tissue association, that's another
few weeks and then they have to
have a degree of maturity that you can
can carry out reproducible experiments and then they last for months
and therefore ma  n always
test other drugs in the same
artificial heart tissue if you
plan it well and insofar as it is usually an
experiment that lasts over a month or
next question how close do the 3d
printed organs come to real organs
i find very complex phases  very
difficult question
we have said again and again we
want to be honest in the einstein center three
and not
raise false hopes we are still a
long way from real organ we are
always trying to get closer and
there is, for example,
competition from time to time  to mention as
a really great
study by an american company that tested two antibiotics
, one of which had proven to be good in
animal experiments and even in clinical
studies for the first time, but one
that these antibiotics had to be
taken off the market later because it was more
toxic and this company  then has
a liver printed and has this
humane printed  Liver exactly this
liver transplant
that appeared a few years ago that
already shows the potential there is
but as I said we always have to go further in
order to get closer to the real
organs or the function of the
real ones as organs is there you still have
a few more years woman worked yourself  since
i also have a non-spectator question
but a child's question from this morning
again the woman asked a few questions why
do so many animal
experiments or laboratory animals have to die sorry
so
fundamentally there is also the
legal regulation that if it's
possible the animals don't die like
i said at the beginning
the majority of the animals that
are used are mice, and if they are used in
basic research,
then of course the organs must then be
examined in the laboratory using
various
molecular biological or biochemical
methods or histological methods in
order to then be able to earn money from these
organs  There are also
legally prescribed gentle
killing methods that
must be learned beforehand so that
the life of the animals is ended as humanely as
possible. The organs can
be removed and then examined further in the
laboratory at the points where this is
not necessary  there are extra
programs that have been developed so that
animals are
placed privately or given
to
farms so there are
such programs that but to be
honest and i would like to be
honest for the
numerically smaller area where that is
possible
okay
here we have  a woman in the audience
thank you exactly
thank you to the rule my question is
actually for the whole group, namely
how long will it really take
to realize this goal that
your organ models and crook models
are validated as test systems with regard to
the risk assessment
that is one
Difficult but correct question
I would like on the one hand  emphasize that since we come from
the academic world,
we also work primarily for the
academic world, which means we are looking for
models on which one can better understand a disease in the max
delbrück center in cooperation with or
alone with the charité
we come from the
research of the academic  world so we
come less from the
safety assessment or from the
classic, as we have just been
explained, from the regulatory in
which
companies develop drugs and i
think we can
further develop models in our center which are then
possibly suitable through further
investigations through validations to put
them in  but
the validation as such
is a highly complex process of
interlaboratory tests between different
locations, etc. which the
academic world cannot afford,
which is also extremely expensive and
maybe you can then say something else,
that it really is a piece of cake  gene world is
so that's also an important
message to everyone here academic
research in the universities
and this area of research are r
ally two different thing
and that's why the t
ansfer often doesn't really work out can y
s that's one of ours  goals because
you can't do one side without the
other the regulatory institution
couldn't carry out validation
if the innovative nut hadn't been developed
by scientists
beforehand and we hope that we can work more closely
together but i can also give
him hope there isn't
the complex organ  models that we
have seen today are
already in the regulator, but there are
already skin models, i.e. the simpler
organs that we can use already
validated, not to
fully replace
animal testing, but to reduce animal testing and exclude substances at an
early stage
that could pose a risk in the medical sector
you could say you can only
validate what is there and
we want to contribute to that very precisely and thank you very much
for the question and with
that we show again at the end how
useful this einstein center 3 is to
bring together exactly the different aspects and
work and research
areas  bundle to try to make these great
principles 3 possible as quickly
and why concrete as possible
thank you very much for the discussion for
the thanks to the audience and until
next time stay tuned 30
performances and see how we are in
ten years and  to talk about it again
thank you very much
[applause]